Oh Frick good wheels comic-con huh who  are you gonna call I call it lifts no  let's call the Ghostbusters let's do it  so he made his comic con in the car but  there were no proton packs and no ghosts  the air conditioning was also broken and  I couldn't open the passenger door so  that might have hindered any goes  something we wanted to do but you never  know goes for sometimes invisible I  don't believe in ghosts but it's really  a lot cooler from the outside because  from the inside it's more like riding  into her first yeah it smelled kind of  like corpses and the air conditioning  wasn't helping it was kind of warm the  driver was cooled out hey dude that is a  sick ride I would ride the comic con to  get in that but it had to be more fun to  do it from the outside yeah I mean we  can keep looking for ghosts if you want  but I really don't think ghosts are real  there's a ghost behind you stay spooky  everyone  you